welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
almost everybody this is ru garbage it's
a show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grew
up classy
after absolute trash i'm your host stage
foley coming at you on a beautiful
sunday morning
not down here in antoni's basement all
right we're coming at you
from undisclosed locations around the
city
kids today we're going to learn a new
word it's called being on the lamb
and they're hiding out from the feds
foley's on house my co-host
[Laughter]
i got an ankle bracelet digging into my
calf we couldn't we couldn't go to
tooties
fully fully had dirty pee
buddy the joint's hot we snuck in the
back door for a minute to get a little
[ __ ] moving around money
she plays ball she knows what it is
kippy kevin james ryan is here with me
gang you know him oh hey gang what's up
thanks for tuning in uh as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and i gotta be honest some of you know
those numbers are true to [ __ ] roof
thank you very much maybe a little too
true to roof
all right and then something else that's
been [ __ ]
hooking the past couple of days i don't
know if you heard about it if you've
been walking down the street
and heard people talking about it that's
patreon.com
are you garbage those numbers are true
okay so [ __ ] get a glove get in the
[ __ ] game this guy's out in left
field with a hockey stick let's go
patreon that's what got us into this
mess that's it
that's what the libyans are looking for
us right now
kippy's kid giving away bad algorithm at
times we're laminate for a couple of
days
yeah what's up guys um no gang just yeah
obviously
we're on it we're on a zoom we had a bit
of a uh there's a you know
a bit of a coved scare that put us all
uh
that separated us a bit so it's just
gonna be being the big man for this week
hopefully within a couple of days we'll
be back neither one of us is sick but
you know you gotta play by the rules and
uh we're going to get tested waiting for
the results and all that so
we should be back hopefully pretty soon
back to today's hopefully she hopefully
she does some [ __ ] home improvements
to the place while we're
while we're not there you know what i
mean me i'm talking like i'm talking
like i need to join a little maybe a
fridge down a basement or something
she didn't care at all man she thinks
it's all a big hoax she's no
mask she's running around she don't care
i don't know why you got to worry about
that [ __ ] she doesn't talk in a southern
accent we like to protect the innocent
yeah right you don't want to give up
talk about
talk about garbage um now you're aware
of my
um i don't know if i want to say
herpes situation oh boy right
but i get cold sores that's it i get
cold sores
i got bit on the hand in a wrestling
match in high school and then i started
getting cold sores by rottweiler
steel cage kept it real what was saying
the other team the other team didn't
have a heavyweight so they got the coach
just brought his dog
hey get out get out there and bite foley
will you
someone's got to bite the big man
hey the match was on the line i had to
do it you know what i mean shout out to
rusty
uh i did i wrestled a girl one time in
uh in eighth grade
how much did you pay
no uh she uh
i felt bad she was on the team and they
you know she wanted to compete and
everyone's like don't do it man don't do
it so i wrestled her we had a nice time
did you call her afterwards
[Laughter]
my neighbor david for several years my
neighbor was a gal
her brother was a big wrestler so she
wanted to wrestle and
yo i think i might have talked about
this somewhere at some point she used to
[ __ ] dudes up really
to the point i remember you i remember
going to like in those big wrestling
matches
like in like the gym at the high school
they'd have like 15 mats out
and there would be hundreds of people
yeah bro they're tournaments i [ __ ]
wrestled regional at
you're would you go council rock bro
we're not flexing your [ __ ]
letterman's jacket i'm telling the story
here what the [ __ ]
okay i understand hey listen i
understand you know what a wrestling
tournament is i'm explaining it for
the listener you got
i've been there the big man almost put
me in a full nelson real quick hold on
relax
you were one of those kids thank you you
were one of those kids you went to
now you went to a wrestling match with
that my brother my brother wrestled
um and our neighbors across the street
and so like i would have to go because
my brother whatever i was there
and she would [ __ ] these kids up dude
and they would dude they would cry dude
i remember the one kid
i felt so bad i felt for him i just felt
for him he went
and cried under this like the the
scorers table you know what i mean where
they flipped the points
of like an empty man dude this is the
90s the saint this ain't the [ __ ]
the new millennium progressive [ __ ] you
lost to a girl
you were [ __ ] moving the family was
you would never live that down no
no no and i just i felt like and she was
good like her brother was
really [ __ ] good so she was like i
bet you know what i mean she was good
and she too she played football too and
she'd be [ __ ] she was a beast across
the middle
you don't want to get you don't want to
get hung out to dry with her she [ __ ]
did she'd [ __ ] take your head off
it's like it was just marshawn lynch's
sister what's going on
i just remember being like oh she's the
tough one of the group like she was like
my best friend and i was like yes this
chick could [ __ ] me up she could have
beat you up easily
i would i mean yeah dude she was
wrestling competitively i was just this
little pudgy kid looking for the snacks
yo hey babe go put this go put this guy
in he'll go pin this guy i'll be at the
snack bar with a slushie and a pretzel
i tell you what the snack part those
things weren't too shabby you get a nice
[ __ ] soft bretzy
yeah [ __ ] a screamer screaming cold
coke
some mom doing it maybe she's had some
homemade baked goods thrown in the mix
oh you ever go to a bake sale they're
pretty trashy i remember we went once
and i
at the at at the church in like the
basement of the church and i didn't get
it like right away i'm like i'm just
gonna buy this food that these [ __ ]
random people made
yo tuts get me they're laundering money
what do you mean that's what it's all
about
it's a big wash get me some tasty cakes
and let's
[ __ ] go what are we doing here
[ __ ] hanging around eating [ __ ]
mrs smith's bundt cake
hit the [ __ ] bricks give me the good
stuff
i was a big fan the only problem is they
didn't serve ice cold milk you had to
wait till you get home but dude you were
getting lemon bars
out of steel it was unbelievable they'd
be like
us that's not us we're like we don't eat
other
i'm not eating other food that other
people made and then sold me for 25
cents or something get the [ __ ] out of
here
well why not you're supporting the
church or whatever it is i don't know
what they're doing
it all seems so buddy the church gets it
the church gets a 20 and a basket every
week now right that's how orion's
operated so
[ __ ] 20 cash look the other way you
know what i mean
is that is that what she would do is it
20 you're lying
no my dad would do it my dad did a 20
every every week
i don't know i used to go to church with
him more but he would do a 20 every week
on a [ __ ] boom
and i felt like i felt like a baller it
was folded up like
half and then half again there you go
all the other bums in there throwing in
a nickel a penny keep the change you
[ __ ]
there you go yeah we were cooking in the
90s dude
we were [ __ ] big ball out of the 90s
a dub every sunday there you go take
that
yeah that's [ __ ] that's a sinner's
mentality right there here you go
he was he was buying time yeah he was
[ __ ] he had a couple he had a couple
of doormen to pay off if you catch my
drift
he owed the boat man trying to get
across that river
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
[ __ ]
trash dude yeah yeah and we and you know
what else is traction someone asked this
at one point and i don't know if
it was supposed to make it to an episode
it just never did or maybe we did and i
forget about it but
uh leaving church after
communion that dude we were dude
oh yeah you gotta get it dude it's like
a [ __ ] it's like getting out of a
[ __ ] wedding
it's [ __ ] mayhem getting out of there
some old volunteer fireman
directing traffic out on 202 i got to
get the [ __ ] palermos we got a
[ __ ] pie waiting for us
are you kidding me yeah you know how we
were gone
my uh my dad i don't know what i don't
like again i don't know what demons he
was dancing with but he wouldn't get
communion
i would go and he would go get the car
and i would get communion and he would
be out front so i don't know
i don't know i don't know what was going
on but there were some there were some
[ __ ]
still waters run deep daddy oh that guy
was dancing with somebody
dude who goes to the old school dad
yeah goes who goes to church drops a
dubski in a basket and then doesn't get
the cracker
good night somebody on the straight
outta hell tour that's [ __ ] what
dude my dad did the same thing and they
would do it
with such honor they would do it with
such
honor nah you go ahead yeah and i
remember thinking like what the [ __ ] did
this guy do
i don't know if he did it as like a mind
game to flex on us to like let him know
that he's been involved
in [ __ ] bad situations with worse
people that he's been hemmed up or what
but it worked because i mean dude
anytime somebody doesn't go to communion
though the rule is you're supposed to go
to confession before you go to communion
like i don't know what the
statute of limitations is on it but
you're supposed to go at a certain point
i think it's weekly
it's before you receive you're supposed
to confess in a perfect world you're
supposed to confess weekly
i'm not saying nothing i give him the i
give him the old yeah live cheat steal i
give him the [ __ ] yeah i give him the
three run down that's it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
give me a couple of hail marys let's go
i was mean to my brother what do you
you know come on what are we doing here
let's go i stole a dollar from the purse
let's go give me the give me the snacks
what are we doing here
well currently right now father i'm
wrapped up in corporate espionage around
the globe
i don't know if that if that counts
i'm a 12 year old on a ponzi scheme
[Laughter]
i had my lawyer killed last weekend um
no what i was gonna say is this is
pretty trashy you know because we got
the covet scare
going on um i uh
you know so i get cold sores every once
in a while just like most people do
um but i got i got one in my [ __ ]
nose
oh that is is that garbage
it ain't i mean dude it ain't i can't
stop no
i can't stop playing with it because
it's like all scabbed up and like if
if i push it in it sticks together and
it gets all brittley
does make for real good picking i'll
tell you that it's at a certain point
now
all right all right this is this is come
on no this is not garbage this is
something else that uh that's oh man my
skin just crawled in here hey i'm trying
to share me what the [ __ ]
i'm supposed to hide who i am yeah hey i
don't need the in those herpes stories
okay
keep it moving with that tuts it was
kind of funny
the screen just paused and then you came
back with glasses on
i wanted to i wanted to do that cat
filter so bad man i know that's
cheesy but dude that thing had that had
me
dying uh i that was one of those things
i was talking it was so funny it had to
be like i thought it was fake i'm like
this is so
fun so funny and so you know it's one of
those things that seems scripted or so
but then it wouldn't be that funny if it
was scripted um but
being that this is a family app what do
you say
we get into a little bit of business big
man
let's get into some questions of course
this is a family up i forgot to mention
that you know we're all in chaos over
here we got a lot going on we'll be back
in the studio
soon um also family up just me and kippy
i gotta be honest with you
when i woke up this morning i woke up
the apartment was clean
all right i had a [ __ ] popped a
little edible you know what i mean just
to get the juices going
had a little coffee took my pills i
stepped out to get some fresh air
it feels like back in the day when we
were doing the [ __ ]
doing doing the early zoom shows me and
kippy this is all we did
this was it come in punch in sit down
check in check out boom
upstairs [ __ ] eggs waiting for me at
paddy's house
not too shabby yeah are you living
are you garbage when you're here your
family ah new tagline check it out all
rights reserved
copywritten i don't think i've ever
heard that anywhere um
but yeah so guys as you know when you
join the
patreon we will read your garbage
questions kind of the only one ways to
do it
because we just get so many submissions
to everything else that you know so when
you join
um the patreon one of the added bonuses
you know benefits as we ask your garbage
question and we'll i know there's
we've had an influx of people joining
we're gonna get to all the questions i
promise yet um it's just uh you guys are
coming in you guys the fish are jumping
on the boat you know what i mean i don't
know what to do with them
um so we're gonna get there um but what
do you say we get
cracking a big man
let's go let's fire some up by the way
when i took uh
when i took some of the equipment from
the uh from the office so we could do
this
a boy did i find a shitload of receipts
from you
and stuffed in one of the things oh man
i feel like i got
i got capone's ledger here i turned
state's evidence
i turned state's evidence tomorrow i'll
be in some whitsac spot in arizona
clean living um
[ __ ] all right give me a sec here
take your time pal take your time it's a
nice sunday morning vibe here
with the family looking out over
beautiful queens
snows on the ground all right let's see
here hey you know what i want to ask
what's up buddy did we talk about this
last week
because i did something really trashy i
uh i didn't take that [ __ ] off the top
of my car
and it really backfired on me i didn't
take the snow off the top of my car
and it was prime situation for it
because it had snowed yesterday
or two days ago and then it froze
overnight
so it was one sheet of snowy ice and as
soon as i hit the brakes man
came right down on the windshield oh boy
not to mention i got
i i got two screws in my tires over
there
i'm gonna have to get two new tires yeah
they fell out of here i got literally a
[ __ ]
i literally i got a screw sticking into
my tire
i got to get one of those uh the plugs
yeah but they don't work because i have
a plug in the other one which they said
will be guaranteed for the life of the
tire and that thing's leaking like
[ __ ] like the hindenburg
um leaking like a school kid after a
fight
or something it's a sunday what do you
mean i don't know insert joke here yeah
yeah um all right so speaking of cars
you're a big car guy
big car buff this is from will campbell
shout out to will on the old patreon air
show
sitting in the passenger seat of a car
and messing with the temperature or
volume dials without asking garbage or
not garbage
you have a lot of rules on this i know
you have very staunch opinions on this
i mean i come from the samuel jackson
school of radio
and uh and and temperature yeah i mean
if it ain't your car you don't [ __ ] with
it sure my girl
i do my girlfriend will just
she'll she'll she'll do it all on the
sly she'll
all of a sudden i'll be like hot or i'll
be cold like what the [ __ ] going on
she was like i was cold i was hot and
she'll turn that [ __ ] down without even
without even uh without even breaking a
sweat now the radio
on the other hand we don't really listen
to the radio we put the the
napster on or whatever it is spotify
whatever sure the aux cord that's the
big thing you grab the aux cord but is
that like uh
does does anybody have you know what's
the worst is when someone puts on a song
when the song isn't the other song isn't
[ __ ] over yet it's like what am i a
[ __ ] jerk off here
like i just put on [ __ ] tom petty let
me [ __ ] rock i got the windows down
you know what i mean we're cruising and
then all of a sudden you want to listen
to the [ __ ] yeah
or somebody no way
yeah hey carson daly stop killing the
vibe will you all right take a [ __ ]
hike you know what i'm saying let it
play
i know i know uh yeah it's trashy yeah
you should ask you know but also
a good host driving a car would ask hey
you're too hot you're too cold you want
to put something on hey you know
something you know sometimes with you
big man i gotta be honest you don't
you don't you know your body temperature
ain't the same as everybody else's all
the time so sometimes i get in your car
and it's like [ __ ] hanging meat in
there
yeah i like it nice and cool and crisp
and especially on a long drive i need to
stay fresh and awake
you need to plan ahead and also that's
what your little vents are for you can
turn your little vents off
in my car i do now i understand i
understand all
all that uh all that uh uh manners aside
when you're in a relationship it doesn't
matter we have a rule
i get like four or five songs and then
she takes it over
yeah my girl will just turn off the
usually what i get she'll just
i'm a big radio i just like put on
whatever and she'll just [ __ ] that's
off i go okay cool i guess we're done
keep it moving she flexes on me she lets
me know who wears the [ __ ] pants and
the checkbook in the family
i like a little 10 10 wins in kyw news
radio
1060. especially in in
in climate weather i always i always go
back to the well of am radio to find out
what the real deal is out there on the
streets it's not in climate weather
inclement weather um yeah it is it's
inclimate weather
yeah that's the i think that's the
origin of the word but it's pronounced
inclement
inclement weather no it's not
climate okay no it's not um
yeah um well according to 10 10 wins it
is
it always reminds me of [ __ ] plow and
snow 10 10
you know 6 10 a.m or whatever that's it
takes you but you
you can't find the weather on [ __ ]
serious and stuff like that you don't
know what's going on
i don't care what i'm doing i want to
know what's going on in the street that
i'm on
the [ __ ] you know sirius can take a
[ __ ] hike those bozos they don't know
what's good
i don't i never understood serious who
wants to choose from ten thousand
[ __ ] channels unless you're
interested
unless you wanna what unless you wanna
get in the [ __ ] ayg game daddy
um i just don't get it that's just too
much for me it's like
you know my what's too much there's too
much to choose from
70s on seven 80s on 80s 90s well here's
here's the here's the give me here's the
good news bozo give me 50 cents first
album or shut it okay that's all i want
to hear
here's the good news it would take elon
musk
and an entire team of his top scientists
to figure out
how to get serious radio in that [ __ ]
hunk of [ __ ] you call a car i know
i don't even i i couldn't even get yeah
i'd have to put one of their satellites
on my roof
driving around with the big dish
driving around one of those v's like
like the limo
got a boomerang on the back that's
classy
gang real quick want to take just a
minute here and talk about one of our
absolutely favorite sponsors
and one of the favorite sponsors of all
podcasts
of course we're talking about sheath
sheath
underwear baby use it get it do
it now yeah guys it is a
fantastic product i've i i feel like i'm
a personal spokesman and
even in my everyday life like in my
group text i'm like guys you gotta try
this stuff out
and then they're like oh what are you
you know you're just trying to sell it
i'm like dude
i get paid regardless if you buy it or
not just [ __ ] try it and then people
are
like my boys are like dude this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] a game changer
if you're not familiar the fabric they
use is the softest
it's i dude i love i just walk around in
my i walk around in my
little [ __ ] got my little stinger look
popping out too in the apartment i
i'm not a not just an underwear guy ever
until i got these bad boys
and now i'm tropsing around the
apartment just uh just in my
my little uh my little skin type boxer
shorts going on but
um there's two pouches there's a pouch
for your wiener a pouch for your ball
bag you can go the wiener in the one
pouch the ball bag and the other you can
mix and match do no
no pouches whatever you need i never
knew i needed my balls off my leg that
was the big game changer for me i know
for you
you're a big guy there's a lot going on
down there you got to keep things in
order you know
the sheath has been a game changer with
the cooling factor i'll tell you that
keeps the [ __ ] nuclear plant nice and
cool you know what i mean
i'm liking it yeah
[Laughter]
we gotta melt we gotta melt down over to
foleys guys there really is there's
really no
no other underwear you should be using
other than sheath we actually
i absolutely love them they're fantastic
i can't go back i can't go back to i
have like two pairs of regular underwear
left that are still in cycle
that i should just throw out because i
feel like i'm dressing up in the 1400s
when i put those like cotton [ __ ]
dvds on
not for me anymore i'm a sheath man go
to sheathunderware.com use our promo
code
garbage you save twenty percent oh yeah
it's a fantastic deal he's telling you
guys
they're you know they're uh they're
they're worth the money
it's it's a game you won't go back i'm
telling you you will not go back to
regular underwear it'll be the best
underwear in your in your rotation uh
sheath underwear dot com use promo code
garbage and support the people that
support the podcast baby
this is an a plus company they love
comedy podcasts they love the show
they support all the other comedy
podcasts get involved with these guys
sheath underwear dot com promo code
garbage
yeah have you told the folks about the
good time we're having over there on the
stereo app
every thursday night at nine o'clock
eastern time that is it is a good time
buddy
hey guys if you're not familiar with the
stereo app check it out it's an app we
do live streams on it we we take your
questions live on the air you guys
send them in it's your voice we you're
here it's a good time it's a really cool
way for you to get involved with us in
the show
i know for me every thursday night when
we started
i crack a couple of ipas i let my hair
down a little bit get a little loose
it's a nice little time for me
it's a lot of fun i got the stereo up go
to stereo.com
kevin ryan or slash h foley we get to
with our beaks a little bit
get involved baby it's a good time we'll
see you thursday nights 9 o'clock right
there on the stereo app
now back to the show yeah all right you
know what i thought of
oh sorry hold on you know what i thought
of during the snowstorm you know it's
really trashy
if your town does like an announcement
of the weather at a certain point like
on the channel or on the radio or
whatever
but it picks a location in the town
where it does it
oh like down at the bank or whatever
we're down here at b and j bank and it's
currently 53 degrees with my
dick up my [ __ ] or whatever when i
when i was home
i heard uh i heard 32 degrees at the
acme in phoenixville
oh on the radio yeah with a 100 chance
of
100 100 chance of percocet
[Laughter]
we uh we do believe the sale is gonna go
through uh
skinny pete has just showed up
hey hey guys we're down here at the
local acme
and uh you know patty foley's credit
card was just declined
more more coming next hour
32 degrees at the acme in phoenixville
31 at the
johnson's pizza two blows down
uh all right great question great
question this is off to a [ __ ] barn
regular already folks um
this is just uh when i say a home run of
a question i'm talking an
hr out of the park this is from benjamin
wagner over there on a patreon when you
preheat your oven does it smell like
frozen pizza
dude you ever just have an oven in an
apartment that just smells
it's just whatever it's just been pizza
for [ __ ] a decade
yeah dude i don't know what happens to
it when it does that it i don't know if
i can identify what the smell is
for me it's like aluminum foil frozen
fish sticks pizza
there's a whole little potpourri of dirt
there's cheese on the bottom
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
cheese on the bottom crumbs on the
bottom because we just got a toaster
we've been using that thing for
everything i can try to close [ __ ]
clipboards yeah yeah i got a [ __ ]
i got a full forge on her
oh that's pretty good they're nice that
ain't too shabby i'll give you that
like i always growing up everybody a lot
of you must you know i was uh
we were a toaster oven family let me ask
you this how many pieces of toast
is too much for one person when you're
at home
anything more than two i like forced now
that's
yeah i mean that's crazy yeah you should
only be
i'm never gonna finish all my eggs
i'm never gonna finish all my eggs which
is two pieces of toast
i'm sure you'll figure it out i'm sure
you'll figure you'll figure out a way
um yeah you know you that's too much i
mean
i think you know that's probably like
the amount of carbs you're supposed to
amount of bread you're supposed to have
for a day
think about that it's multi-grain it
doesn't matter it's multi slices is what
it is okay that's still too much
yeah let's get that down to three let's
get that down to three okay big man we
gotta we gotta keep an eye on you
um new multi-loaf bread yeah uh great
question
yeah uh next one coming up this is from
[ __ ]
a home run of a name on this guy jack
columpus
shout out to jack clonton
which guys i posted i had a problem with
the door
the door won't open why
jiggle it take the pen remember how mean
the wife was
the wife was such a [ __ ] she's like let
him come down and get his own raincoats
like you have nothing better to do
what's he gonna
with these old dusty raincoats um
for if you're not jack compass is uh one
of the hump [ __ ]
you know one of the greatest characters
from seinfeld shout out to jack klompus
who me and you are jack and morty
seinfeld
i'm jack compass you're morty seinfeld
really i'm morty i think so i'm the i'm
the i'm the smaller angrier one you're
the
you're the bumbling doofus a little bit
wearing a number one dad
i got the hotter wife huh mr seinfeld
will do shabby
she was all right i remember her i i
remember her on alf she was on a show
called alf
you might have been too young alien life
form yeah there's a hair in my thuna
fish
yeah i know what elf is what am i a
[ __ ] jerk off
there's a hair in my teeth so it was a
it was like an original
but yeah it's a line from an episode of
elf
whatever moving on uh jack klompus's
question is
have you my friend or no jack clump have
you ever taken more than a penny from
the take a penny leave a penny thing
which in my bad days i've been hemmed up
and i would you know
yeah it's time for 20. yeah kidding me
you know what always bothered me too is
when somebody would pay with something
with change not
not judging them that they're paying
something for change i've been there
a bajillion times i get it i'm still
there whatever
i remember i remember going to get
snacks at the [ __ ] on on when we
lived on titan street
going around that corner to that [ __ ]
dirt ball gas station and [ __ ]
getting like
ten dollars worth of snacks with all
quarters in the lean days
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure um but
bring hippie back
shout out to the combo when people would
pay with change and then like
they would get like 27 cents back or
something from you know their
their transaction and then they would
put that in like the leave a penny take
a pic i watched a kid buy sigs one time
newports at a wawa
and paid in full change when they were
like you know
eight bucks or something paid eight
bucks and change
and then they she gave him like the 16
cents back or whatever his change was
and he like threw it in the leave a
penny take it pen he's like i don't need
this i'm like no you
clearly need this you know what i mean
like where do you get the confidence
to start you just left all you just left
your whole net worth
in the leave a penny take a penny thing
pal you need
you that to get down to an ira quick all
right third point matter of fact take
the rest of it yeah
um i'll dabble i'll dabble
i'll dabble and we'll leave a penny take
a penny thing and you know what's
only you know makes you feel like a real
like a million bucks hold on hold on
well you confuse the guy too will you be
like yo i don't think you
know math well enough will you be like
hey
your price will be like 761 you'll give
him like 15.82 and be like
make him do some crazy [ __ ] math
where you get like a quarter and
seven ones back or something my dad was
huge on that
just give you know after trying to
misdirect him no
after you know they would get like you
would pay
right and then the guy would enter you
my dad would pay with a 20
and the guy would enter 20 enter and
then it would be like oh
you know your change is 761. and my dad
be like well i actually have 14 cents
here
and then the guy had to do some weird
penny that's the
worst ah it's so much they
yeah that [ __ ] used to drive me crazy
i'm like he's a 14 transactions done
once the [ __ ] transaction is done
that's it there's no it
once the wheel starts spinning buddy
there's no more no
no more bets all bets are closed i know
i do i usually get if i try to do that i
usually get to well i already rang it in
that's always a good answer i already
ran it in sorry yeah
if you want to give me the change i'll
give you a dollar
but you know what i was gonna say you
know it makes you feel real good when
let's say it's 7.52
7.52 cents and you give him a 10
don't worry about the two two cents you
always feel like a big shot like ah
thanks man
you know you know what i just had
yesterday i popped into the
old bodega i went outside i didn't have
a lighter to catch a bernie
so i popped into the bodega and i didn't
have any cash on me
and he's like i pulled out my card and
he's like you don't have cash i'm like
nah this is it he's like yeah get it to
me tomorrow and then i went in this
morning and [ __ ] broke them off it
was great
yeah it was nice that's like you feel
like a [ __ ] wise guy you know what i
mean
i had that with a slice a couple weeks
ago my spot to grab a slice
and i only had my card he's like just
get to get it to me tomorrow like ah no
problem
pretty slice next time i saw him i gave
him a five you know how it is
huh you know what we're doing here let's
go boom boom boom
leave a slice take a slice that's how
you operate
a little dish of pepperoni right next to
me
take a couple of these a couple of
garlic knots for the road
what are your thoughts on the garlic
knot by the way
i don't i listen this is going to be
maybe blasphemy i've i've never had
i listen i i i've been eating [ __ ] at
pizzerias my
entire life almost 45 years
okay i never had a really good
exactly garbage i'm saying on paper
the theory of them fantastic sign me up
all day
but you rarely get like a really [ __ ]
good one it's always the insides a
little dry
or it doesn't [ __ ] i had them one
time yeah it's weird
this place i used to work called santo
palato my first job ever i was busting
tables at like 12 or something
wait dude i the there was like an
italian bank
[Laughter]
maybe it was a bank and i was just there
eating p i was just there eating pizza
and spaghetti the whole time
but they used to make their their garlic
knots out of like
it was like proper [ __ ] pizza dough
kind of you know what i mean it wasn't
like
i don't know that's what they all are i
know but this one they did something to
where they these were actually good but
they don't do it for me they give you
the cup and then you dip the stuff and
it's just you know yeah they're they're
fine if i'm in the mood i'll be like yo
let me get treated m
or something you know what i mean they
do jack them up which is pretty good
which i've had [ __ ]
i've had them all pumped up with when
they put mozzarella cheese and sauce on
them and then bake them in the oven
that's not bad
but then you got pizza that's a pizza
that's a pizza
what are you talking about hey can you
can you make that a pizza and then i'll
say yeah come on what are we talking
here
you put a slice of chicken on there um
never had a good [ __ ] garlic knot man
would love to
don't don't want to hate on the garlic
knot but would love to have a good one
someday
um yeah i also i don't know if i
mentioned mention this to you but i
think
i'm going and this is a little bit of
seinfeld influence
uh i think i'm going all sicilian
as my pizza i'm a sicilian guy from here
on out
i think oh that's not too shabby older
it happens as you get old i remember my
dad used to eat it and that was like
you know you might as well been drinking
black coffee as a cat i'm like what are
you doing
for eating [ __ ] scenes yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
a slice of sicilian you were like what
the [ __ ] is
wrong with it you had to have a foreign
issues yeah it doesn't get communion
yeah yeah you had to have a 401k to get
a slice of cecilia and you couldn't just
you couldn't be like a [ __ ]
12 year old in order to slice a sicilian
nah
didn't it did make sense i remember one
once or twice my parents getting like a
whole pie
and i'm like who's coming over like what
yeah
what militia is he is eating dinner with
this get rid of this [ __ ] and get me a
round pie
[ __ ] eight inches and get some
[ __ ] some peps on there okay
yeah you know who used to do it real
nice pizza hush pizza hut used to do a
thin crust
oh buddy they're thin crust you could
[ __ ]
mulch through that thing i felt i felt
like we were [ __ ]
i felt like we were french or something
when we got one of them things coming to
the house i was like ooh la la
kippy like
dude you think i don't know about the
french bed or about the uh about the
thin crust i was a big domino's thin
crust guy
[ __ ] whoo good night and that's so
very good
that they cut it in the weird way that
we were talking about the other day they
cut it european style
[ __ ] yeah yeah like a checkerboard
yeah um all right next one coming at
this is yes or yes
tank 69 at any point in your lives have
you ever considered
triple x or vin with vin diesel or swat
with colin ferrell great movies
and i would like to say i thought swot
was a [ __ ]
uh a cinematic masterpiece for like at
least a year in my life until i realized
it was just a big hunk of [ __ ]
but it wasn't too shabby if it gets you
at the right age
those movies you catch where you know
it's just explosions a hot chick and
colin farrell good night sign me up you
know what i mean
early 2000s that we they really leaned
into that where
they took like the 90s model of like
action movies
but they really over the top cheesed
them up real
sexy the the the pinnacle of that would
be the miami vice
that he was in him and jamie foxx which
i think it was a [ __ ] great movie
but it was all about that nobody was
using their regular voice
it was all i'm going down to cuba for a
couple of d's
every lion was like that every line
you're holding the line it's gonna get
edgy it's gonna get tough out there
you sure you got the stones to make it
happen and it was always some informant
that didn't want to give anything up
but he was a real [ __ ] dirt bag
[ __ ] fantastic i never
[ __ ] with vin diesel at all
what what's triple x what is he a
[ __ ] triple x
superhero or something no if i remem
i've watched it for sure i think he was
like a
stunt guy or like a bmxer or something
and then like the government hired him
to like
you know jump the statute yeah they
hired him to like jump the stats
in front of 7-eleven yeah it was
something i think he was like an extreme
sports star i don't know if he had super
powers but like i think he's like put
down that mountain dew
put down that mountain dew and taquito
you got to save the world
yeah it was very it was very that i feel
um
but yeah i mean dude those movies hit me
where i was like especially
[ __ ] that and yo bad boys too bad
police two
got me that was once that's [ __ ] way
different
i don't know that was the same thing
dude explosion it was all just dude they
have the line and
when those when like they assemble the
the squad of like you know all the rogue
cia guys and stuff they walks into the
room and yeah the one guy goes
you guys look like you're getting ready
to do something stupid
sign me up and i was just like cheese
city daddy oh
but yeah they're great movies they're
fun
but trashy yeah they're trashy movies
that's how you entered every gymnasium
from there on out same place yeah
they're for every high school parties no
i wanted to say there is a vin diesel
franchise i don't know what it's called
his eyes glow it's something in space
yeah his eyes glow he has
it's uh that's like the camera it's
called midnight or something like that
yeah it's something
you can see at night some something
something says night vision yeah
yeah yeah yeah that those are pretty
good
i [ __ ] with those uh yeah i mean
that's garbage
that's garbage yeah if that was the
question it's garbage down the line
yeah bring up vin diesel you're trash
guy does all right though
a lot of cash except in his uh
performance in saving private ryan shout
out
um all right next question come on
that's
we call it marzo went out hard oh he
called my buddy caparzo after for i mean
all for years because of that
um all right this is from adam k which
tattoo is trash here a tribal armband or
the words only god can judge me
as a friend as as let me let me chime in
here as a guy
whose friends have you know multiple of
these
both of the origins of tattoos the
trashier one is only god can judge me
because it's like a message right it's
like an identity like you can't [ __ ]
tell me what to do i'm you know this
rebel to society or tribal armbands they
were just hot for a time you know what i
mean so it's like
you know you got caught up with the
wrong crowd for a couple of years and
you gotta you ended up getting a tribal
tattoo that was more of a trend only guy
can judge me as like a [ __ ] you think
it's a lifestyle you know what i mean
you're like
i'm [ __ ] this is what it is and it's
like nah dude
you're a [ __ ] dork hit the bricks
and and and with the tribal armband
there is the
small chance that you might be
samoan hawaiian or something like that
where
i think that's all actually it could be
aquaman or [ __ ] the rock or something
like that
where it actually is it means something
yeah it fits you
yeah i don't think that's what he's
talking about
there's no religion there's no nothing
that has [ __ ] only god can judge
attached to it
that means you made a grab at one of
your cousins or something like that
yeah yeah yeah exactly you're too you're
trying you're trying to [ __ ] explain
some [ __ ] without that too
um this is from jessie
this is from jessie gertzman which i've
nev man some questions
they just [ __ ] take you right back
have you ever had a radio slash cd
player mounted
under a kitchen cabinet in your home
oh my god my buddies had them and i
never understood that i'm like well
i at one point i thought it was like
fancy that and a tv in the kitchen i was
like oh my god
but then as i get older i'm like tv in
the trashy though tv in the kitchen
is great my brother trashed it right
they just moved
now but they had this [ __ ] beautiful
little kitchen
and they [ __ ] slapped a little tiny
uh
uh flat screen like in the corner had it
mounted and [ __ ]
oh it makes it real cozy in there
watching good morning america
while you're [ __ ] christmas morning
some [ __ ] going on
got the parade on real nice
you're like oh you know christmas you're
setting the scene you're making it all
romantic
but like if you're [ __ ] you know dude
i would still be on a tuesday
if there was a tv in my kitchen i would
stand there most times standing up and
eating
just feeding all the all the [ __ ]
endorphins just going at once
yeah i mean you're trashy that's the
thing you sometimes you forget that just
because you like
something you go that's not trashy no
you're garbage and that is [ __ ]
trashy
okay okay moving on
sometimes paulie gets fully just really
falls in love with something and then
goes no i love it yeah you can love it
it's trashy
okay i love five five five hold on
the dad who did put the cd player or
whatever underneath the cabinet
it never worked for more than five years
some wires
came loose that was the same dad that
like wired the whole house with speakers
so you could hear the music anywhere
that [ __ ] never worked
that always broke at some point yeah
yeah yeah you have something pretty
trashy and yeah we have
too we have the intercom that can go
from room to room
that was i mean the house was built in
the 80s that was like the height of
[ __ ] technology you know what i mean
an intercom you can go
room to room and then also you can go
neighbor to neighbor kevin stop jerking
off up there or come down for dinner you
can talk to the neighbors
like front porch or something like it
goes to like one speak i don't know i
it never fully we never used it or
whatever but there was like a cassette
player on it it was weird we never
really [ __ ] with it but it's still
there and it's like the fake
wood paneling that's buck county militia
[ __ ]
no that was like that was like i think
they were building these nice houses
back in the 80s and they were like this
is technology right now but in like
three
technology was moving so quick then like
three weeks later they're like well this
is trashy
you know or it doesn't like make sense
people are like oh this is gonna be cool
but then it you know
it wasn't right away
ah it's garbage garbage cart
garbage all right this is uh this is
from tony p
did your parents ever make you lie about
your age or to get a discount or reduced
admission
on anything i don't think we ever oh
yeah
oh yeah i was 11 for a while
up until a couple of weeks ago i was 11
for a while
i don't know why you didn't save that
much man
i remember i recently asked my mom about
something
one time i might have mentioned this
before so if i did i apologize but
we one time went to a drive-in movie all
right
it was me my uncle mike's family we all
we all went to a drive-in movie together
we took multiple cars okay this was
probably i think this was in
wilkes-barre they had come up to hang
out with us for a couple of weeks or a
week or something like that
and um a couple of weeks we weren't
driving
hold on if you got family coming for a
couple of weeks that ain't good
something's happening maybe a week maybe
a week
a weekend three-day weekend at most if
it's a holiday
maybe ah no we used to [ __ ] settle in
to get our rooms organized i ain't going
anywhere
break out the break out the lifesaver uh
the the lifesaver sleeping blanket uncle
hank's staying for a while i used to
love it
um anyway we're driving to a [ __ ]
drive-in movie
in the early 80s admission
couldn't have been more than a nickel
yeah
conservatively maybe five bucks
maybe five bucks and there was like 10
of us
but for some reason as we were pulling
in they made my one aunt
get down on her hands and knees in the
back seat and we put a blanket over her
to cover her up
oh my just i don't know why that's
enough yeah just
unless it was just like you know my dad
and my uncle mike just trying to
like [ __ ] the system you know what i
mean just like you know giving the old
finger
the finger or whatever you're a couple
of working guys you know what i mean
they're busting their stones
why not get a little something on the
slide i don't know why we did it but i
was always confused about it and i
remember i asked my mom not that long
ago and she's like wow that was
expensive back then
i spent the drive-in movie in the 80s
come on paddy yeah that's that's
that's unforgivable that's tough that's
tough to justify
that's really hard to justify i mean you
got a grown woman hiding under a [ __ ]
you know an igloo cooler to save three
bucks ain't good it ain't good
maybe i shouldn't be talking about it
what's the statute of limitations on
something like that these days
yeah i think the wilkes-barre drive-in
is uh they're not coming after you for
the for the three bucks
could be a cold case out there you know
what i mean [ __ ] looking for the
foleys
uh big ass [ __ ] station wagon wood
panelings old school as it gets
in the back seat giving the finger to
every car that drove by
clean living um
this is just funny uh this is from alex
tonello
on the patreon have you have you got the
vaccine because you smoke or you're
obese
i tried to i know i tried to get it but
they're
but [ __ ] you know got our boy cuomo
over there is [ __ ] backpedaling
surprised i'm surprised that guy's still
around surprisingly not hiding out in
[ __ ] italy
like michael corleone at this point
hitting the lamb that guy
they got coming to eat's coming down on
him but they were supposed to have it by
february 15th
where fatties would be able to get it
you know
and i just thought you know since it's
available you know that i should go get
it
you know so i can start maneuvering
around a little bit more
you know especially now you know we've
had of course we've had multiple
multiple scares playing defense on this
thing
but i know when i went onto the website
they said um
i didn't qualify so
i went into hoagie and came back and i
qualified
maybe maybe maybe [ __ ] go get a pizza
or some garlic knots that'll put you
over the edge
i don't know how they checked that
though like they didn't ask for my
weight or anything like that or any kind
of documentation to say that i am
obese i guess when you pull up they're
like all right yeah go ahead fatty you
know what i mean
[ __ ] yeah i think if you're just so yeah
i don't know i think they put they put
the needle in it put the needle in a
cheeseburger
[Music]
i think they're also a piece of ham like
an old dog yeah
wrap it in cheese you're so far behind
yeah um
great question funny question uh this is
from christopher uh
guilty over here did you ever have a pro
wrestling name picked out because i for
sure
wanted to be a pro wrestler we used to
do backyard wrestling
you know we were [ __ ] you know yeah
we were
that [ __ ] was huge in the 90s or like
early 2000s what was yours naked kevin
something i remember i had a move where
like i would just like try to rip
like i would like i know i was trashy
dude i was young we were probably like
10 11 when it hit like with like
goldberg and stone cold like that [ __ ]
was huge at that time
and i remember i it was like i would
just like pull on the guy's neck
like i would just like i don't know it's
just like a [ __ ] and i
[ __ ] [ __ ] this kid up real bad like
not like
like i like [ __ ] hurt his neck and
like his mom had to call my mom and
it was like i was like dude we were
wrestling what the [ __ ] you know what i
mean i was going ham what do you want
from me
hey your little fat kid's going around
putting kids in a camel clutch
that's if i can pull it back a little
bit yeah this guy
super fly kevin snuka over here no we
never [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
i was a wrestling guy for maybe like a
couple of weeks in the 80s
when the hulk was big i watched the
cartoon they
they had a cartoon saturday morning
cartoon him and the junkyard dog going
around solving crimes or some [ __ ] like
that
i was into that i didn't like the toys
the toys didn't do it for me
now i can i can appreciate them but if i
didn't have full mobility
i i couldn't i couldn't do my do my
fantasies
yeah you know i know i get you
you you when you're yeah i'm a gi joe
guy
i got you i'm with a daddy oh and i'm
not hating over here
um great question this is from uh jack
which i'm not even
really sure i i fully understand this
garbage question
have you ever given someone a random
gift card in exchange for them paying
for your meal oh okay you know i get
that one i thought it was something else
um you know like oh here i owe you 15
bucks for
you know the red lobster i got a best
buy gift card with
20 bucks on it i'll give you that type
thing
anytime you're dealing in gift cards
anytime you're any time
anytime you're operating with gift cards
it's bad news it means you're hemmed up
is what it means
that and store credit currency store
credit's a bad look too
no you've never who's ever given
somebody hey i have store credit over at
[ __ ]
boss golf oh i mean you know in our in
you know in high school days or whatever
junior high days that was like
when you know you never mind that was i
mean people would i would hear it i
never did it or you know i'd be like hey
i have this if you're gonna go there
anytime soon you know what i mean
are you going to are you are you are you
going to pep boys anytime soon
oh man yeah trashy i bought
i bought something illegal one time with
a stereo
what do you mean like traded
sure yeah that's not bad you traded a
[ __ ]
you you traded sound equipment for
[ __ ] coke or something
that's i did not say that i know i'm
making a joke buddy it's a comedy
podcast
uh kevin ryan kevin ryan said that
ladies and gentlemen
um this is from alex sherman does anyone
in your family have calvin payne on some
pain on something sticker on their car
which i have to say
if you if you're not on the patreon we
do it in the foley's crib
foley has one on his house foley's
family has
the calvin guy peen on something on the
house i don't want to give it away
because it's on the patreon
but if i can check out the foley cribs
edition on on patreon the video
he's got one on his house i'll give it
away i'll give it away you want to go
[ __ ] check it out should i not give
it away for that purpose
i'll go check it out yeah it's calvin
with a little sailor hat
pissing on the name jane fonda and
that's because she entertained the north
vietnamese troops
[ __ ] during the vietnam war which my
old man was in
and none of the veterans like her
because of that and rightly so
some commie [ __ ] to me um
it or leave it baby uh okay let's burn
through a couple more here this is for i
mean i think you've touched on this but
uh i don't know uh this is from andy
have you ever used
toilet paper or have you ever used paper
towels as toilet paper which i know you
prefer
prefer i prefer it i prefer it i rip
them in half
and get like you know playing card sizes
but it just
it just it gives you more grip you get
more power
all right better steering
and it absorbs more sure i'm gonna buddy
i'm i'm on
sometimes with you sometimes with my
diet
okay or lack thereof uh
that could be a never-ending thing down
there be there for 45 minutes
just going and going and going and going
and going and going and going
i need something with a little grip i
got to get in there i got to get in
i breach i don't do you breach when
you're when you when you're wiping i
breach
what's that mean i'm in there i'm
in there i don't i don't know what in
there qualifies for you i'm sure we're
playing different games
uh but yeah i mean i you know i take it
from the business different
gravitational fields are involved
sure sure i take care of business you
know
i wouldn't say i i go dumpster diving
but i'm you know i'm taking care of
things
appropriately what needs to be um
oh yeah all right next one what was the
exact question
the exact question was do you use paper
towel yeah yeah which is yeah the big
man prefers it which i don't mind either
um from carrie anne have you have you
slept in your
have you slept in your work clothes so
you can sleep as late as possible
the next morning before your shift which
is
insane to me that ruins the night of
sleep to me if you're sleeping and she
goes
i often did this as a teen working at
dunkin donuts if you're sleeping in a
dirty dunkin donuts t-shirt in your bed
you are trash and what's definitely in
my jeans a couple of minutes
a couple of minutes i don't get it a
half an hour at least if you roll out of
bed and [ __ ] splash some water on
your face
brush your teeth real quick and you're
at the [ __ ] door you don't got to
stop for coffee
it's true you get coffee at work that's
all you're waiting there for or
breakfast
yeah you got to be rolling right in the
[ __ ] so you're rolling in there
you're fixing yourself something nice
i'm trying to make the donuts oh i used
to sleep in my jeans
i used to sleep in my jeans all the time
i know but but it takes
two seconds it takes two seconds to put
jeans on to go to work if you're not
showering you're not showering so take
that out of the equation if you're just
waking up and putting jeans on
that's what seconds 15 seconds
ready to go yeah i sound like i get
dressed and then lay down i'm already
dressed and i'm like i'm just gonna wear
this tomorrow
and i lay down and go to sleep and then
wake up and i'm at the [ __ ] door
okay either way you're really a
go-getter when you're doing that
i bet you elon musk does that i bet you
i thought of a question the other day
don't get the mars
have you er that's not true he wears the
same thing all the time look at steve
jobs he won the same turtleneck for
[ __ ] 25 years
yeah i'm sure he doesn't guys killing it
i'm sure he doesn't i'm sure he doesn't
sleep in them
how many of those you think he had a lot
a lot
enough you think he had a lot hundreds
yeah hundreds
yeah because i i had a question the
other day have you ever taken a shower
and then put dirty clothes back
on i did that with underwear just now
right before we recorded i put a pair on
last night like a new pair i think i got
out of the shower and put them on midday
yesterday
and then i was like oh [ __ ] i gotta hop
in the shower before this
to like just [ __ ] wake up and i just
threw the same undies
sheath underwear by the way sheath
underwear promo code garbage
oh yeah yeah the only underwear
fantastic product
yeah um yeah yeah all right let's do one
more and then i gotta jump here buddy
okay
let's do it baby we love you guys we
appreciate you hanging in there with
this little zoom episode
little throwback [ __ ] mondays we'll
be back in the studio
this week i assume yeah this one's just
funny this is from uh oh [ __ ] i lost it
sorry oh
[ __ ] um this is from uh
jeremy have you ever been the only guy
dressed to hip hop or two rock and roll
at an event
like a family event or anything there
was some times when i was listening
when i got into rap in like sixth grade
where
i for sure i was the like i would show
up to like thanksgiving
trying to be [ __ ] mason puff daddy
from the mo money mo problems video
ah you must have been so [ __ ]
annoying i remember my mom would be like
putting that kid in a [ __ ] food i had
like i had the real baggy jeans and i'll
be like put the other jeans on we're
going to a nice event you know and i'm
like
nah you don't get me while i'm trying to
spit my rhymes or something in the back
of her minivan
ah you must suck
yeah it wasn't good it wasn't good ah
that's [ __ ] too funny i've seen dudes
i've never i was never that that
into either one
but i've seen the dude that shows up
that usually what's a telltale giveaway
is the
the generic baseball jersey open
oh that's a remember just like yeah
like the hat yeah yeah yeah yeah and
like you you're wearing a hat at a
funeral like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
yeah it's not a good embarrassing people
that is not a gang what an exciting
episode
we love you guys thank you so much
we appreciate thank you guys we
appreciate all the all the love and yeah
appreciate all the love and support
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes the full video
available on youtube and then
patreon.com
we're having a good time thanks so much
for the support we love you guys
peace peace hold on a second there gang
before you start stepping out the door
want to take one more quick second and
talk to you about the fun we're having
over there on the stereo app and it
doesn't matter whether you have an
iphone or an android
you can download the app for free and
you can sign up
and we have a [ __ ] good time yeah
guys it is a lot
of fun like we've said the past weeks
get involved we're having a lot of fun
in there you guys
are giving us it's an easy way for you
to get your question you know for us to
riff on your question make funny
we make fun of each other get involved
go to stereo.com
kevin ryan or slash h foley you sign up
we get to at our beaks a little bit it's
a good time every thursday 9 p.m eastern
time
see you this week do it